اود ان اسالك كيف خرجت من من فيتنام لاحقا
كل الضغوطات كانت عليك كما قرانا وكما
تابعنا خلال المدرسه وخلال الجامعه
واستخدامك كاله دعايه سياسيه همم لم يكن
مريحا بالنسبه لك ما تقررت الخروج وكيف
خرجتي ههه
بسببي اني فقدت حريتي وحياتي كلها لقد
شعرت انني فقدت كل طموحاتي واصبحت حياتي
كلها اله مكرره للدعايه السياسيه كانت كل
احلامي مركزه على هدف وحيد هو ان اصبح
طبيبه اساعد اشخاصا اخرين تعرضوا لنفس ما
تعرضت له كانت لدي رغبه عارمه في العوده
الى الدراسه في احد الايام ارسلتني
الحكومه الى موسكو لحضور مناسبه دعائيه
وصادف ان رايت رئيس الوزراء فطلبت منها ان
يساعدني على استئناف دراسته بسبب ذلك
ارسلتني الحكومه الى كوبا لدراسه الطب
هناك كانت فتره اسوء من الفتره سابقه قضيت
ست سنوات لم يساعدني فيها الطقس بالمره
حيث اثر على حاله الصحيه لكن الامر الجيد
الوحيد الذي كان قد وقع في كوبا بالنسبه
لي هو لقائي بالرجل الذي سيتزوجني لاحقا
كان ذلك قبل 30 سنه بمناسبه زواجنا سماحه
لنا الحكومه الفيتناميه بالذهاب الى موسكو
للقضاء شهر العسل هل تتخيلين شهر عسل في
موسكو لقد كانت فرصه للحريه ففي طريق
العوده من موسكو الى هافانا حطت الطائره
في تيرانوفا بكندا للتزوج بالوقود عند
فتره التعبئه نظرته لزوجي وقلت له امامنا
ساعه ولن اجبرك على ان تدعني فقد اتخذت
قراري فهم انني قررت القرار والانعتاق من
الطوق ووفاق لقد كانت مغامره من اجل
الحريه خرجت من الطائره وهو معي ومباشره
عرفنا مكان طالب اللجوء هو وقفنا هناك ومن
وقتها بدات قصه لجوءنا في كندا قبل ثلاث
سنه
اكثر ما كان يزعجك في العيش في كوبا وحتى
للذهاب لروسيا لم يكن مغري ابدا بالنسبه
لك في شهر العسل فقررت الهروب الى كندا ما
هي الصعوبات التي واجهت في كوبا يعني
الشيء الجميل انك التقيتي بزوجك هناك لكن
عن الاشياء الاخرى ماذا يمكن ان تحدثين
في دوله الشيوعيه صديقه هي كوبا جعل امر
السيطره ومراقبته هينا على الحكومه لقد
ازعجني ذلك كثيرا كما ان نتواصل مع اسرتي
كان صعبا جدا لقد اضاف ذلك صعوبات اخرى
على هجرتي واستطيع القول انني في الواقع
لم احصل على اي حريه هناك سواء من حيث
التنقل او العيش لقد كانت السنوات الست
التي قضيتها في كوبا صعبه جدا كنت اشعر
بالوحده والبعد عن عائلتي وكان علي ان
يكون للاتصال بمسؤولين حكوميين كل نهايه
اسبوع كما ان محيط الحقيقي والطق يساعدني
بالمره واسهم في تازيم وضع الصحي وبصفه
عامه فان اي شخص بامكانه ان يشرح لكم هو
الوضع صعب في كوبا وبالتالي لم اكن انا
الوحيد التي عانت من العيش هناك بلد
كثيرون هلا بس تناقشتي انت وزوجك في موضوع
الهروب الهروب الى كندا من الرحله
المتوجهه من موسكو الى
كوبا هل تردتي كيف اتخذتي القرار بانه في
هذه اللحظه تريدون الهروب والفرار لتصبح
اللاجئين في كندا
نعم نعم في البدايه حقيقه كنت خائفه
ومرعوبه ومتردده في مشاركه فكره مع زوجي
وانا علمتني الطائره تحول ذلك الخوف الى
خوف من عدم تكرار الفرصه فصليت ان يبقى
زوجي معي ويوافق على اللجوء معي فلمحت له
وفهمني بمجرد ان قلت له انني لم اجبره على
المغامره وان القرار يعود له فوافق على
الفور وقال لي معك الا ان يشاء القدر
ونجحنا وانا ممتنه جدا للحكومه كنديه على
منح فرصه الرجوب وفرصه اعاده بناء حياتنا
في تورنتو